please in the northern state of Uttar
Pradesh are not taking chances they
advance while firing tear gas at
protesters who are defying a government
ban to congregate in large crowds every
tactic is being used to quash nationwide
protests against a new citizenship law
the police are being accused of using
excessive force
what started as a student demonstration
has grown into a larger movement to
denounce what governments often and say
is divisive and discriminatory
legislation the law excludes Muslims
from neighboring countries from
receiving Indian citizenship which goes
against India's secular Constitution the
unrest in India has been discussed at a
conference of Muslim leaders in Malaysia
Prime Minister Martin Mohammed said the
India law is unfair to exclude Muslims
from becoming citizens even by due
process I think is unfair so we have
voice our our disagreement with this
kind of treatment India rejected his
comments saying the law doesn't impact
the status of any Indian citizen or
deprive any Indian of any faith of her
or his citizenship the Malaysian Prime
Minister's remark is factually
inaccurate we call upon Malaysia to
refrain from commenting on internal
developments in India without the right
understanding of facts on Saturday
protesters packed the streets of New
Delhi despite the government's ban on
large crowds
lawyers from India Supreme Court and
High Court's joined the outcry we are
one how can they discriminate among
Hindus Sikhs jenni John and Muslims if
our Constitution allowed us allowed
everyone
we're outside the Jamia Millia Islamia
University where the protests first
began the university is now closed but
students are still gathering join my
people from all walks of life art
students depicted the Constitution and
the government's attitude to it by
painting this street but it's also this
the idea behind it which is so vicious
the idea behind the act it's so vicious
that every thinking human being everyone
in this country will be affected and
therefore standing up Indians here are
vowing to continue their defiant revolt
against the law and say they won't allow
the government to destroy the very
fabric on which their nation is built on
Sabina Shrestha al-jazeera New Delhi
India